amazon founder jeff bezos has announced
he's heading to space with his brother
next month on the first manned flight
launched by his rocket firm blue origin
they'll join whoever wins the auction
for a seat on the new
shepard spacecraft on july 20. the
world's richest man says he's dreamed of
going to space since he was
five blue origin is facing stiff
competition from
elon musk's space x richard wurtz is a
professor of aerospace engineering at
the university of california at los
angeles
and directs its plasma and space
propulsion lab he's joining us
from los angeles thanks for your time
with us how big a deal is this
um it's not really a big deal from the
sense of
aerospace technologies or or launch
vehicles
this is really about just commercial
space
uh space flight for for wealthy people
that would like to
to launch into say it's really a high
altitude you're not launching into orbit
um so it's not really a big deal because
you're really just launching to a high
altitude
and then coming back to earth right and
we understand
that bezos won't be in space
for that long just about 11 minutes so
is that what you're referring to
yeah yeah so he'll he'll be just in
space for 11 minutes basically he's
going to
up to about 100 kilometers he'll
and then he'll just come back down right
gravity pull
instead of it to go to orbit takes about
10 times the rocket so
to go into orbit you would need to go
something
like 27 000 uh kilometers per hour
in the direction perpendicular to
vertical
right to the side and then you go into
orbit around the earth
so it's good for people who want to say
they've been to space
but this is not going to orbit got it so
tell us about the rocket the new shepard
i understand that
this particular rocket is reusable what
does that exactly mean
um what what we're doing these days with
launch vehicles which we haven't done
uh too much of the space shuttle was the
first rocket to
really demonstrate a high level of
reusability meaning
the rocket that you go up on can come
back down
be refurbished and then relaunched and
so that it is very important uh it's an
important idea
however it's it's been demonstrated
before
um quite successfully by spacex
um so there's not really a significant
um a significant technological
advancement here
do you foresee any challenges with this
trip
i do um i would say that
it's it it is interesting that
uh i think there's a little bit of a
publicity stunt here or maybe a lot of a
publicity stunt trying to
show a level of confidence with his own
technology
which which others may perceive as a
good idea
but the way it usually works with launch
vehicles and especially when we're
launching humans
is it's not about the expense or
of of the last person to go on uh or the
value of that person it's more about how
many times has that rocket
been launched before successfully
without a failure and
most importantly without a loss of life
got it and what do you think the
messages
behind all of this and of course we have
to mention that there's elon musk spacex
there's also richard branson's
uh virgin galactic as well do you think
that they might do the same thing
um they could i i again i think it it's
it's a um something that uh
jeff bezos wants to to put his company
on the map and say we're here
and we're ready to launch people into
space and he's confident enough to put
himself on top of the rocket and do this
and i there definitely are always
challenges this is this is a dangerous
industry um and i
i would i would be concerned honestly um
i don't think it's important that the
ceo goes up on a rocket before
other people go up i think it's much
more important that we do a lot of safe
launches
before that with with or without humans
on that rocket because there's so many
things that can go wrong
with the rocket because a rocket is
essentially a controlled explosion
and so it's more important that we do
many launches
many safe launches than it is that we do
a launch with a particularly confident
individual okay thank you so much very
interesting to speak to you richard
wurtz
joining us from los angeles okay thank
you